kiki berichtet sarah benutzen was
verstehe ich nicht hätte ist ja voll
hässlich schmerz ja es ist soweit
was ist hier null los also lange hat
jetzt ein rezept von mir nach ich finds
richtig schade weil dieses rezept das
sind die nuss hörnchen und das seit mega
altes video und dadurch wird es halt
einfach nicht mehr kleben ich habe vor
kurzem seine story bei mir angefragt ob
die leute möchten ob wir das nochmal neu
drehen also die algen ist aber neu
trainer genau damit 70 prozent jahr
gesagt ja und jahren ortner kam auch
nach ich dass ich habe vergessen bis
jetzt nicht egal ich ja aus der fassung
also ich hab doch ganz einfach ist ein
ganz einfaches per brücke die nuss
händchen bestehend aus einem teig und
der teig besteht aus drei zutaten butter
mehl und doppel regal
ich schwöre euch ich hab das rezept das
letzte mal gewesen als ich ausgeflippt
haben das war zwei beendete war ja ich
kann mich noch erinnern wie das war ganz
grün aber ich habe keine andere zocker
wirkte jetzt spüre ich habe keine ahnung
also hansa seine erste aufgabe besteht
darin diese drei zutaten mit den händen
auf keinen fall vom händewaschen
nein mit den händen geht auch einfach zu
verarbeiten kann
ich lasse dich religion oder so kannst
du bist ok ich lasse dich in ruhe was
ich machen das einfach alles reine jetzt
hier
kiki über 11 das einfach so rein
alles zusammen rein ich bin so hilflos
also bitte ist man einfach das alles
hier ein okay
was die drei zutaten die ein spiel schon
verloren ich weiß ja nicht was noch
alles okay aber so rein raus musste hat
jetzt raus nehmen
du musst bisschen lauter reden wir haben
ein mikrofon sorgt euch jetzt in die
hand genommen bist du dass du kommst
eine klar auch mit der schärfe und sowas
werden als entwickler kommst ich kann
dir helfen da kennt auch tauschen
aber das ist hier dass das ging einfach
okay ich möchte dass ich habe schöne
hände aber ich wollte ihn nicht dreckig
machen wo ich hab noch nicht mal
anschaut kann man hier schon gerissen h
okay das ist einfach genial wie lange
das ist ja ich habe mein leben noch nie
so was gemacht wird ist keine masse bei
mir wird das massaker ok der erste
schritt habe schon versagt ja toll house
liegt dass man da hinten und hilft mir
einfach mal gibt man ja ich guck mal was
da los ist
ich habe mich damals falsch wenn man
also wir haben eigentlich kurz vorm ziel
aufgegeben den herrn stores gaben zehn
sekunden geknetet dass ich schon wieder
gut aus ja aber das ist echt das war
echt komisch gerade bei mir aber das ist
so richtig
ok ich kann halt jetzt ausgebrochen
[Musik]
geschafft ohne hilfe ganz alleine stolz
schulterklopfer also richtig mit fremden
lorbeeren schmidt nein das ging nicht um
hamsa bei der hat er du hast ergibt
zusammen gepresst stadt geknetet aber
gnädig mandat sei minuten amateure die
das aufstechen gemacht haben sie machen
welche westerfelder weg
was waren wir viel bedeutet haben sie
jetzt ist der tag noch richtig irdische
liebe ich genau deswegen müssen wir den
frischhaltefolie einwickeln und kultur
und leute 60 minuten wenn man den schön
flach drückt dann kühlt er schneller
durch also muss ich so was geht jedoch
reicht kann ich noch einmal benutzen und
wie lange
april schrank für 60 minuten 60 minuten
später dass hier ein das gericht
gewissen wenn wir die hälfte hier genau
ist weggenommen
die kinder sollen die hälfte nutzen weil
die wahl wir müssen früh angefangen
haben also nach gefühlten zwei stunden
und wo es nur drei tische waren geht es
jetzt weiter
jetzt musst du halt die zutaten brauner
zucker weißer zucker und hasen
vermischen und dann den teig auf dieser
mission einmal aus und jetzt noch mal
auf deutsch
ok so ist das erst mal hier rein tut
oder so ich werde mit ihr die hälfte der
aufnahme unscharf sein
[Musik]
so und jetzt mache ich das hinlegen
das war's
wir haben in der schublade wo auch die
gespräche du hast jetzt was ich
schubladen da sind sehr viele schubladen
das soll es dann zu sagt sie herumgehen
auch von oben dachgeschoss was runter
holen und die rechtsfolgen präsentiert
wir sehen allerdings hat apple sorgt
okay es geht weiter auf dem weg durch
den teig hofft er muss das mischung also
das jetzt auf dem boden liegen also ein
bisschen frecher so schlimm da sammeln
ja okay jetzt das auch den boden leben
nicht auf dem boden sondern auf die
arbeitsfläche also auch die
arbeitsfläche so und jetzt auch ich
gerührt ist es schlimm
jaha kiki verlängern das schön machst du
hier so eine back deutsch hier kannst du
mal die sprache sprechen die ich spreche
mich darüber zusammen so die nasa
und wohl den auf den mann auf der masse
und aus er fragt mich ist das trotzdem
warum suchst du mein gesicht heimlich
aussehen könnte ich habe meine nase
störung mir war schon heute so einfach
ist hier drauf hin
[Musik]
du kannst sie schon vor sagt das doch
vorher wie grund so lassen sich einfach
mal machen
ach so meinst so weiter www denn außer
muss ich jetzt versuchen das klebt jener
zeit auch mehrmals wenden ihn - mischung
aber das ist immer so verstehe ich nicht
was du können mehrmals wenden so ach so
ich dachte manchmal gibt hier gas und so
man kann hier so rainer geht man das
worum es da geht automatisch los also
einen tag freundlich mit waren geil oder
eine idee
geil was machen
das ist rund und nicht gern also nur zur
info ich kann nicht zeichnen ich kann
nicht mal ich gebe betriebe bin ich ein
looser
das ist ein herz fasste und dann kommt
das nicht herzkrank herz es ist nicht
höher und kommen dann auch das ist
deutlich zu dünn ausgerollt kommen dass
man jetzt einmal deine hände geht es
genau herkommt weiß was egal wir lassen
uns jetzt so ist okay also ich finde es
nicht gut dass man ihr schreibt man die
kommentare so schrecklich aus der
anhänger habe ich schon so etwas macht
der typ da also wenn ihr das seht also
standpunkt alle frauenherzen weißt du
gar nicht geredet uns von gut und genau
das will ich von euch wissen glaubt ihr
standpunkt wir unsere zähne zu gucken
funktioniert das ja man schreibt sie
jetzt in die kommentare
jetzt oder nie wieder was das tram
sachen zulegen was muss man zuhören
also ich weiß nichts mit
was ist das das logo drauf mega sag mal
ist das da 1 bis dahin war das muss tor
sein
und weil die klinge nach syrien scharf
stelle stil germany bon jovi sogar cool
nicht aus china es ist okay heute geht's
los jetzt mit dem pixar walter dörr
gesagt ich kann nicht zeichnen ich kann
nicht mal wie soll ich das verschneiden
einem schaffst du hast wie eine pizza
jetzt oder was die aktivität gespielt
und wir sind dinge zeichnen wir haben
sie so verloren so idee ist ja voll
herzlich egal
das sieht aus wie so eine wärmeflasche
anfang wodurch das wasser rein tust und
erhielt zu verbreitern ausgehen ich bin
schlecht in die geometrie so die wird
auf jeden fall nicht gleichmäßig sein
das weiß jetzt schon dass ist ordnung so
bleibt es jetzt ja so einfach geht's auf
ok von hier oder verbunden
ich komm ja ich kann auf die andere
seite schau dir die stadt jetzt mal
richtig über die schulter holst du dir
einmal auf ein spaß ist kaum kommen hier
ist bisschen die kirche so schlimm so so
so toll
[Musik]
war das schon ein bisschen rein knicken
damit dass im synchron charakter erhält
ein bisschen schicker aus wie machst du
das so einfach das ganze teil einmal wie
so ein halbmond
also du nimmst es sowieso ein halbmond
also
da muss man erst mal so wenn aber tricks
sagen halten wohnt da weiß man bescheid
aber es muss jetzt etwas sage ich
fotografieren jetzt werden richtig sagen
der bild ich versuche also hier auf und
dann das war's ich muss weiter machen
dass sich jeder tritt spaßig der ist
richtig schief guck mal wie schief der
jetzt kommen noch kommt man das und das
ist hier keineswegs iquadrat richtig
schlecht komme der iss herzlich ich
etwas sage ich jetzt machen soll
guck mal wie es ist jetzt kommt kann ich
nicht so machen komma vorschlag oder
dann machst du dann mit dem rest
das kommt natürlich nicht in die
mülltonne nein spaß das packen wir super
drauf
das kommt einfach so kommen wir das mal
wieder so eine mini ein schelm also so
daneben liegen das ist der große bruder
von ihnen müssen
okay das ist ja keine bruder ab geht die
post
ich würd mal sagen wir sehen dass gleich
wieder die reste verschwinden machen das
schön so ordentlich noch was hängen
liegen wo noch immer das kommt es den
ofen aber ich mache ja genau 100
90 das ist immer ober unterhitze immer
so jetzt ist sich eingeschaltet
die zweite stufe 2 das kam jetzt 95
grundsätze und ich weiß nicht wie dann
16 bis 18 minuten habe ich doch gesagt
gerade offenbar auf offene tür auf ich
wusste dass diese smart home habe er
richtig cool also einlegen des welches
fachgebiet wie lange ja das habe ich
gerade gesagt immer auf dauer hier 16 16
und dann kommst du wieder aufgehen
ich weiß was ich mache 17 bis gleich
das dokr nein das ist interessant was
machst du denn jetzt doch die küche auf
zwischen optimal eröffnet sich schon die
spülmaschine
wenn das kein omen ist
spülmaschine mag dich mach ich das jetzt
wohl gegeben habe vor kanada war und ich
ja gleich ganz ehrlich ich habe es
geschafft gebacken
du musst aufräumen
[Musik]
die 22
voraufgegangen die erste sowie gut aus
die zweite katastrophe los war hauptmann
schmeckt das sieht einfach zu groß als
dass blätter tag wäre dies mit der kraft
des handschuhs hole ich raus mein gott
sind die hessen
[Musik]
diese äußeren kommen haben so etwas
findest du gerade schmerz das ist halt
jetzt kommt die analyse warum woran hat
es gelegen
man fragt sich wo herz legen aber was
wir legen
ich bin jetzt den finger jetzt und alle
wünsche sind mein mund ja auf jeden fall
dabei kommen die japaner aber die sind
nie
ich will das gar nicht sagen aber meine
mutter stolz auf mich wieso aber ich
benutze und ich das verkaufen also die
hier sind dünner als die und deswegen
sind die natürlich schöner brauch des
lernens tipps leben ja gesagt nicht
einmal ein mal wöchentlich leben aber
ich muss das ausziehen muss ich muss ich
nicht mehr ich drauf habe es ist ich
habe gesagt ich hab mich sehr sagt sag
ich dir deine sind schöne hause meine
sind geschäftlich der sieht so aus das
ist ein anfang an hätte hier probiert
vergleich aus wie es schmeckt konnte
müssen war es abkühlt man ruhig mal
sagen ich habe die aufgabe erfolgreich
versaut
ich habe mal sagen dann bis zum nächsten
mal ich vertraue ich recht ich kann halt
ich warte warte ich kommt der abschied
ist ja viel mit soll stärker alles
geklärt
das ist doch gar nicht so schlimm
bisschen hässlich gegeben
ich weiß zwar nicht warum wir hier auf
dem boden hocken versorgen ist macht man
das so wenn man ihm versagt und das sagt
ja okay dass ich mal sagen bis zum
nächsten mal was wir versorgen aber
trotzdem haben wir aufmunternde worte ja
das wäre schaum und deine worte wollen
ein bisschen verstören dann schreib doch
den haben sowas nettesten dabei sag ich
mal sagen ich liebe dich trotzdem dafür
dass du mich dafür dass ziemlich dafür
auf basta brauchen diese sowie dafür das
wird aber auch noch mal ganz schnell ein
probieren aber es ist doch heiß da sieht
aus wie verbrannter käse kirche kennt
ihr das mit diesem toaster macht diesen
toaster nach unten drücken dann aber als
ich später mal verlängert
sie mit dem rennen war ich bin ein genie
der krise geil
ok diesmal aus kenia und wieder auf ich
hab's geschafft dass ich das gar nicht
gut zu verschmerzen kann ich mir gut ich
bin erstaunt darüber berichten wir
müssen so im jahr machen manchmal gut
wenn ich das ja dann würde ich mal sagen
was eine wende um doppelt eine wendung
des falls hätten wir alle nicht gedacht
dass man respektvoll stellen damit die
kamera aus der hand
danke fürs einschalten bis zum nächsten
mal auch das tor getroffen ja
versprochen
[Musik]